palais direction le château de cheverny
à présent comme dans une vingtaine de
sites en val de loire la féerie de noël
il fait des merveilles une tradition
vieille de 30 ans avec sapins décorés
bonbons à foison et bonhomme géant en
par des pis elle n chapelet nous fait la
visite
au château de cheverny en plus des
figures historiques ou habituel de la
famille depuis le 1er décembre toute une
ribambelle de nouveaux personnages ont
fait leur apparition dans les
différentes salles du monument l'esprit
de noël a envahi les lieux de quoi
émerveiller le regard des visiteurs ou
qu'ils se posent je trouve ce château
absolument féerique et j'aime en
particulier la salle à manger en bas
avec tout le bas cette grande pièce
aussi féerique et la chambre de l'enfant
avec ce grand signe super robot c'est
super beau beau coup de boule beaucoup
de décoration
kas 3 est aussi oui est ce qu'on a vu
belle salle à manger une belle table
décoration pendant l
des chocolats oui
il paraît que la gourmandise est un
vilain défaut c'est pourtant le fil
conducteur de la visite et personne ne
va s'en plaindre car à noël on a surtout
envie de se faire plaisir
c'est également ce qui vide la maîtresse
des lieux dans le choix des décorations
qu'elle met en place depuis 27 ans
on a un budget assez que le sale pour
noël trente mille euros et par an on a
été obligés de construire une grange
pour abriter tout ça parce que entre le
thème de noël le thème de pâques quand
n'y arrivais plus voilà donc au grand
désespoir de mon mari on a dû créer un
bâtiment
en plus de toutes ces décorations à ne
pas rater l'arrivée du père et de la
mère noël en hélicoptère sur la pelouse
du château rendez vous pour cela le
dimanche 12 décembre pour une journée
encore plus spécial
[Musique]